[Music]
foreign
a dead guy shows up in my door
Revenge
should have stayed dead
I can get in I can get in
I know I repeat myself
you're ruin my snacks
an ax
I don't want to fight you and this is
gonna end quicker
you know we don't read
driving four knocks on wheels
see me shining baby
we're locked inside it's a trap that's
the bomb all right dorks what are we
blowing up what the Vatican
you guys are going to hell
foreign
I'd never be the man I am today
and now I am the man that's going to
break your family
Peace by peace the devil's coming
dummy I knew you would come for me well
how about we all just start shooting
each other
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
we need weapons
cars
adding cars do you like surprises I
adore them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down you lose
the last ride
then you might want to buckle up
thank you
[Music]